hello everybody cool to see so many
people here I've got some fierce
competition from John skeet now so
lovely to see all of your hair like to
introduce was our first my name is
Frances Paulin work a web step I'm a
full-stack developer and I'd like to get
started by showing the reason that I got
into hacker and and the things that I'm
going to talk about in the first place
so I work at ABB they've been my my
client for the last two and a half years
worked on various different projects
there and the most recent project that
I've been said to work on is to build
the front end for an electrical
simulator so that's basically a
simulator that simulates electrical
circuits or but rather large ones so
huge generators and motors and things in
in factories or oil rigs things like
that and they've been so kind as to let
me let me demonstrate this so I'll show
you what we've built and then I'll go
through some of the technology and how
we got there
but with a slightly simpler coding
example towards the end so put this in
you'll see so what we're looking at here
is an electrical system that is being
simulated off to the side here you can
see all the changes that are going on so
that would be voltages that are changing
currents that are changing changes in
the frequency and these changes then get
pushed to us every 10 milliseconds so
there's not a lot of time between each
tick to actually render stuff out so
this then gets piped into the into the
active system as messages and then we do
some do some things with the messages
and then we send them up via signal our
to our redux and then then it gets
rendered with with react so what this is
really useful for is for example if you
want to do training to see how a system
will react to different user inputs or
for example if you need to take out a
generator for some plan maintenance you
can see what will happen if I just
disconnect this generator on the spot so
we can try and do that now so we've got
three generators that are connected and
we can see what's going on here and you
can see that they're all within within
the specified load that they're rated to
but if we then if we close this switch
here you can see that immediately the
load becomes too high for the generators
and they're starting to struggle so then
you could you could you could then find
out that if we then take out what I have
to know is a very high load and then
disconnect the generator then we'll
still be fine and I can also be used to
test systems that do this automatically
it's also called load shedding load
shedding systems so that you can you can
program that these motors aren't
particularly important so if we haven't
got enough power then just cut them out
so so it's quite cool it's almost like a
game so it's been really fun to fun to
work with so that's that's what we've
built and now I'd like to show you how
we built it
could you see the presentation now you
can see my desktop
but better so some statements to get us
started distributed systems are hard
writing applications that scale on
demand is hard and threading and shared
state can be nothing short of a
nightmare
some of you are probably good at this
and don't think it's hard but I find it
incredibly difficult so I appreciate
having frameworks to help me do this
kind of stuff so that leads us to a
cadet net and as we were researching
technology to use to make this simulator
I was listening to Donna crocks and then
interview with Erin standard and we were
talking about a cadet net and he's one
of the core contributors and I thought
what this sounds really cool and it
sounds like it could be useful for for
the thing that we're building so I
looked into that and turns out it was a
good fit and if you look at the website
you have this little thing up there that
says we are reactive and what does that
actually mean well if we click on that
we get sent to the reactive manifesto
and that is four principles or traits
that define a reactive system so the
system should be responsive so that
means that if a user so a user could be
a person it could be a machine there
could be anything asks the system
something it should get an answer it
might not necessarily be the answer that
you wanted so it could be that the
database is down or something like that
but you should least get an answer and
also the system should be elastic
meaning that in response to high load
the system should be able to scale
itself so that you can you can continue
to serve your customers the system
should be resilient it errors happen we
all know that it's impossible to make a
completely failsafe system but the
system should be able to heal itself and
deal with that and not just throw its
items in the air and give up and also it
should be message driven so that
basically means that we send send
messages to each other and that allows
us to do some interesting things such
having location transparency for our
code in terms of that it can be running
in different places but we'll get more
into that a bit later so what exactly is
the actor model it's a conceptual model
to deal with concurrent computation and
a method of concurrency in which the
universal primitive is an actor and that
might all sound a bit fluffy but just as
in object-oriented programming where the
class could be seen as the as the
universal primitive then in in actors
then it's the actor bits the universal
primitive and there are any similarities
in terms of like if you would in if you
were coding object-oriented style you
would you would make a class for things
and in many cases you would make a
corresponding actor and it's not a new
idea it was first published in the early
70s so along with many things in
computer science the things things come
back again much later so what exactly is
an actor when an actor can be pretty
much anything you want it to be an actor
is persistent so it's not like a thread
that when it's done this thing it just
like disappears off it the actor will
hang around and wait for messages unless
you kill it or it dies in other ways and
actors can have internal state which is
which is very useful and an actor has an
address so like like you will have a
reference to a to an object here you
have an address to an actor and an actor
has also has a mailbox so if you send a
message to an actor's address it will
end up in the mailbox and the mailbox is
basically just a queue so each actor has
its own queue and then handles those
messages so what can an actor do actors
will then react to messages that are
sent to the mailbox and actor can send
messages to other actors but also to
itself an actor can create new actors
child actors
and an actor can decide what to do with
the next message so an actor can has
this notion of behaviors so that you can
put it in put it in a different state
and then instead of having lots of
ghastly conditional logic so if this
then that then you can just put it in
put it in a state and then it will do
what you've decided to do in that
particular state so that may allow you
to have much cleaner cleaner code some
very important principles that I like to
observe as always the single
responsibility principle you don't want
to have some kind of god actor that that
does everything just like you don't want
some kind of God object that does
everything only interact with an actor
through messages if you start mixing in
other ways of communicating to the actor
and there are exceptions but only in
rare cases then then all of the
guarantees that the actor system
provides you and go out the window so
you don't want to be doing that because
because that can lead to unsafe things
happening and exactly one message is
processed at once
and that's one of the most important
than useful traits that you have with an
actor system because that means that
when you send a message to an actor when
that's processed you can view that actor
as a single-threaded program even though
you may have multiple things going on at
the same time and different actors and
you will never then have to be worried
about race conditions in your actor
unless you do weird things that because
you because it is breakable you can
shoot yourself in the foot but if you
follow these principles then you should
be okay and along with that messages
must be immutable you don't want
messages suddenly changing in transit
time because then also you can have
unexpected side effects actors live in a
hierarchy so all actors have a parent
that supervise them and that also goes
for when you make an an actor at the
root level there will be system actors
that supervise them again so
there will always be supervision and an
actor can send a message to any actor
independent of its hierarchy and that
doesn't necessarily mean that you should
do that but you can and it can be it can
be very useful and you should let
children do dangerous things and from a
parenting point of view that might sound
a bit scary but you want to send scary
things further down the chain and I've
got a picture here that we can use to
throw because if actor one sends a
message to tag to be one and what it
wants to do with that message could
could potentially be dangerous for
example it might do something over a
flaky network connection it might be
doing some computation down here from
data that you know might not be quite
all right so instead of doing everything
in there and then risking that one
blowing up what you can do is that you
can delegate it to a child and then if
something goes wrong then the mess the
exception is sent back here and then you
can decide in B one what do you want to
do if something goes wrong so you could
then choose to restart C one or you
might choose to restart C 1 and C 2
because there's some connection there or
if B one has no idea what to do with
that exception they can just send it
further up the chain and then for
example up here you might decide to
restart the whole lot here because I
could be seeing this scene as one unit
it depends but that's also very useful
and that's how we we create systems that
can heal in the event of things going
wrong so to create the active system
itself
innaka use the static great method on
actor system and you notice here that
I've got two different variants of that
we have one that takes in the
configuration and then we have one that
doesn't and they're both the same really
it's just that the with the one that
doesn't take in an explicit
configuration object that will then read
the configuration from your app config
or web config or
or other places that you could even put
it you can you can use the application
settings of Jason if using s banette
core but you'll have to write a little
thing in between there which we've done
in our project to get it to work because
that isn't supported out of the box but
I'm sure that will come in in due time
so if we look at this piece of code here
it's a very simple bank account so if we
look at that then we can see that if
multiple threads try and do this you
could end up over drawing the account
because two people could be mutating the
balance at the same time and what would
be pretty bad
so you could stick a lock around it but
in my opinion that's quite ugly and the
lock of course isn't part of your your
logic it's not it's not interesting
that's just because it has to be there
so it it just clutters so what we can do
instead if we implement this as an actor
we have the exact same algorithm but
instead of a method we receive a message
which in this case it's just a simple
int and the beauty of this is that
because only one message is processed at
a time that means that you will never be
able to send in two things
simultaneously and overdraw the account
so to create an actor though Tuesday and
it might seem a bit involved but you get
used to it after a while first you need
to create what's called props and props
are like a blueprint or a factory for
the actor but it doesn't have to create
the actor so you send in a send in the
lambda that is run every time the actor
actor starts and then it calls new
client bridge actor and then sends in
any dependencies that that might have
and then the actor is actually created
by using the actor system or the context
actor of sending the props and then you
pass in a name and the name here is
optional it will be assigned a name if
you don't give one but if you don't give
one it will be some name that is if it
is not as obvious as it might be and it
can be useful to have have names if you
want to do routing for example because
then you can have that one under that
one and if you have some kind of
gibberish name then you won't be able to
do that so when possible always always
give a name we talked about the actors
have addresses and the address may be to
a specific actor but it could also be to
a load balancer slash proxy kind of kind
of object or note sorry actor so for
example if you're doing clustering and
you say that you want to deploy five
actors of such-and-such on a remote
machine then you would have one address
to all of that and then you could choose
what kind of distribution you want do
you want to round-robin or do you want
to send your messages to the actors that
have the shortest queues that there are
many options that you can you can use
them but just be aware of that the
address might not always be to a
specific actor and the address looks
something like that in its simplest form
so it's the protocol and then the the
name of the actor system and then slash
user like we saw on the picture of the
hierarchy previously and then the name
of the actor and that will be more
complicated if you're doing remoting
because then you will have demo actor
system at that the host name and we'll
look at that a bit later and this is
what provides us with with location
transparency so your code doesn't
necessarily show at all that things can
be in different places are deployed on
different machines but you can change it
through configuration afterwards so
sending messages to actors there are two
ways that you can do
either you can use tell to send a
message or you can use for word or you
can use ask and when you tell an actor
you send the message and then you send
in the context here and self is the
default so you don't actually have to
specify it if you would want it to be
yourself but you could want to send a
message on behalf of somebody else and
that is basically what forward does
forward is the same as saying who acted
on tail message and then sender as the
second parameter here so it's just
shorthand for that but you can also use
ask which can be useful in some cases
but when you use ask then you say I
would like you to give me something
within this time span here but that also
means that the actor can't do anything
in respond to other messages during that
periods you are basically locking the
actor so you lose some of the benefits
of the model itself by doing that so
only only do that when you absolutely
have to parents know about their
children as one would hope seeing as
they made them and they can also of
course communicating with each other but
you should limit knowledge between
cousins and below and the reason you
want to do that is because if this
cousin one here would like to speak to
cousin two then you you have you have to
have a dependency between them here and
it also means that you would be harder
to refactor if you for example wanted to
change this and you wanted to put
whatever cousin was doing in - child -
then you'd sudden you would have to go
into here and change and it would be a
lot more work than it would have to be
so what you could do that instead is
that this one here could send a child
one which could then Ford to parent that
could forward to child two that could
forward to cousin and that might seem a
bit involved but what school then
because you forward it all the way
over there then when this one wants to
respond you can just say send adopt l
and it will go straight back there
because it's been forwarded all the way
around and it's the sender has been
passed on all the way and you also have
some lifecycle hooks in an actor which
you don't have to use but you can use if
you want to for example do some cleanup
before an actor is shut down and then
you have the pre-start method which is a
bit special so it's almost like a
constructor but it's only run the first
time an actor is created so if an actor
restarts that will get run as well but
you can see that in post restarts the
way it's run is that post restart called
pre start so if you have something that
needs initializing once but you don't
want to initialize it on subsequent
actor restarts for whatever reason the
actor has to restart then you can just
override that and then take away the
pre-start call and then it will only get
run the first the first time by the by
the accent actor system switchable
behaviors that we mentioned slightly
before they are really cool and super
useful so in this case here we have an
actor that has two behaviors it has a
behavior and B behavior and it starts
off by you say become a behavior and
become just takes a function that has no
parameters just a void method and it
will then do its thing when it receives
a string and it will print out from a
behavior but then it says become B
behavior so next time a string has been
told to this actor then this code will
run so that means that you can build
quite complicated state machines like
that but without any ifs and buts at all
which is really really useful and there
is also a version of this called become
stacked so if you for example connect to
something but then you want to go back
into the disconnected state then you
could say the
some stacked and then in the connected
State and then if it somehow disconnects
you could just say become unstacked and
then it will go back to the previous
state so that you don't have to keep
track yourself of what state you're in
before everyone you can pop that onto
the stack onto the behavior stack and
then use that to navigate backwards and
forwards and we use that quite a lot in
the in the simulator and it's been very
very useful remoting so I've mentioned
this a couple of times now that but in
in academic an run our actors on any
machine not just local machines it could
be a machine on the other side of the
world for example if you have a actor
model running on a little computer that
doesn't it doesn't normally consume many
resources but sometimes you need to do
this massive job or something like that
that needs lots of CPU power that you
could just offload that onto a different
machine do its thing and then you could
kill the actor afterwards if you wanted
to security up until acha 1.2 there was
no security when you send messages back
and so forth so that was all in plain
text that changes in echo 1.2 so you now
have TLS and one thing that you need to
be aware of when you're doing remoting
is that your message needs to be
serializable because otherwise it of
course isn't going to work across across
the network and mentioned it slightly
before you can do clustering so not just
deploy one actor but you can make
clusters of actors that will then appear
as as one actor but actually be
absolutely many more so which leads us
to our demo and I'm terrible at drawing
things on the computer so I just drew a
little sketch here I hope you can read
it so we're making something that's
quite similar to the simulator system in
that we have a message producer here
which is just a console application that
produces messages containing the numbers
- 1 - 16 I think it puts them onto a
queue and then an event is raised on the
other end to the listener which is a
queue actor that then receives it or it
starts publishing messages up to the
Fibonacci actor so that that then just
gets the numbers 1 2 or minus 1 2 to 16
and then I actually have to compute the
Fibonacci series for that number and
that is of course a very scary operation
because if we get in - one that is
invalid so that will then cause our
actor to to throw an exception so we've
set up the Fibonacci actor here to
observe this one here and look after it
and restart it when it needs to need
needs restarting and afterwards that
then pushes its messages to the client
bridge actor which serves as our bridge
between our back ends over signal are up
to the client where you can then have n
clients that sit and watch Fibonacci
series being computed so this is
probably the world's most
over-engineered Fibonacci program but it
is what is so let's look at some code to
change to duplicate
can you see is it okay on a black
background or fly change it to white
background yeah
I'm completely lost now tools
hi there we are thank you though this
doesn't look I am I actually running
some code
this doesn't look like it normally does
options there we are that looks more
light
Tepera Oh oops
anyway
so we have our message producer here
that uses a very secure cryptographic
stuff that I don't understand to
generate these numbers and then it
pushes them onto the queue and that is
all this program does so if we then move
to the web application we go to the
startup class this is an Mayer's banette
core app and we go to the configure
services so we need to add two things
here we need to add a service here that
can do that can get hold of our signal
our hub because the akka system will
need some way to get hold of that and
that is then used by the iHub context
accessor that will actually provide us
without with our hub and we need to
enable signal ah and down here we then
pass in a function that we can use to
then get this single our hub and then we
say demo actor system dot create and if
we then we can just look at this quickly
all it does is just give you give you
the give you the hub and we can look at
that quickly the hub here does nothing
in because we're only pushing data from
the server to the client excuse me there
are no methods in here that can be
called from the client but if we were
doing doing this both ways then of
course there would be methods here then
that we could call so if we go into our
demo actor system here then we send in
how hub context accesses that we just
just made and then we take in some
configuration but actually at the moment
we don't because we haven't made any
but we'll get to that a bit later so
we're building buildings three-act or
making three actors we've got the client
bridge actor which is the one that does
the the single a stuff so we're going to
look at that if I got it open yes we
have that receives a Fibonacci series
message so that's when it's been
computed and then we'll just push it up
through the sing sing the live event
pusher which then pushes it to all
connected clients and we have our
Fibonacci actor which is like a parent
actor so that takes in a reference to
the client bridge actor when the actor
riff and what's important to note that
the AI actor if that is not a reference
as in a dotnet reference to an object
that's just basically the address to
which we can send messages and that then
creates the Fibonacci series actor which
is the one that does the answer of
computation and it will receive the
Fibonacci series message once it's been
computed oops
which just lit just looks like this
immutable and it takes the source
message which it got from the cue which
just contains a number and this is our
supervisory strategy so this is where we
decide what happens when things blow up
so if it's an argument out of range
exception for example - one that will
trigger that it will cause the actor to
restart otherwise if it doesn't know
what to do with it then it will just
stop it just for sake of demo and if we
look in our series actor that receives
the Fibonacci source message with our
number and then it computes the
Fibonacci series and then when it's done
it tells back to its sender our series
and also note here that we've got a log
so that the log provider that you can
order several logging providers that you
can you can use this one just logs out
to the console but there are lots of
different ones that you can use if you
want to have something else so if we if
we were to run this or we can we can do
that first then we can see what it looks
like
and
then we can see
so you can see that this is now pushing
stuff to the queue and you can see that
they're being received and they're being
computed at the same time and hopefully
a minus one will appear soon as luck
would have it this is seem to take a
while but the joy of random numbers but
if we wait a little while and we then we
should see that there are some error
messages that turn up off to the left
here and this isn't going very well
now there's one and then you can see
that it restarted but the system just
carries on doing its thing so it
survived that nicely so instead of
riddling your code with prior CAPTCHAs
and then trying to get back into a good
state it's really nice to just to be
able to restart things start at a clean
slate and then just get back to work
again
so we can then have a look at the the
front-end for this because that's quite
fun as well
so we have how many people here have
used react and redux before and have
some knowledge of so a couple of you so
basically you have you have a store that
has your states no no do not take survey
and you then update the state and then
based on that then your your components
are are rear-ended so we have a store
here that keeps our state and that takes
in that's about previously the Fibonacci
series array and then it takes in an
action which is of type ad series action
which just has has one of these series
with it and also here it's important
with the principle of immutability so
instead of mutating the state what we do
here this is of course very naive and
not the most efficient way of doing
things but it's okay for demo purposes
we return a new array put the new value
of the topic at the beginning of the
array and then we spread our previous
state over the rest and then we have a
component that just renders this which
is what we saw before with the numbers
coming out but the really fun part here
is this piece of middleware which is
what allows us to have a message driven
architecture from end to end all the way
up to the client so this this little
piece of middleware here we then I'll
show you where it's registered
afterwards but we connect to our hub and
do all of that the signal our thing so
if you were using a different WebSocket
framework or server sent events or
something it would be slightly different
but the principle would be the same you
connect to that and then when you when
your mess
is a pushed then you dispatch an event
or just more dispatch an action and then
that gets it will then appear in your in
your reducer that we just looked at just
like any other action that was
dispatched for example if you click the
button though or what have you and then
going the other way
any action that you trigger you can then
you can then intercept here for example
if you if you remember in the in the
simulator every time you press a button
to open or close a switch for example
that triggered an action in redux which
was then intercepted in the middle where
and then it gone that got them pushed to
the server and then that did its thing
and then it pushed new messages back
again so you have this two-way two-way
thing which is really nice and that's
pretty much it so what else can we do
here that's fun so we've now got
everything running on one machine which
is cool but what if we wanted to do our
computation in a different process we
can start by doing in a different
process on the same machine so if we
then look at this acha console here
which is what we'll use to host the
process then all that we're doing is
that we're making an actor system and
note that it's not good demo actor
system this is PI actors is to make but
it could be demo active system but I've
given it a different name so you set up
an actor system somewhere this one
happens to then be on the same machine
and you say you give it a port and you
configure the serializers if you thought
very briefly there was a yellow message
as soon as we started the demo
previously in the console that's an
error message saying that the Jason net
serializer is deprecated and that you
should use the Hyperion serializer
instead so this is what we've configured
here now and note that we're not
creating any actors all that we've done
is that we've got a program that has a
reference to the same project
has the actors and the messages that are
being sent but that's all that we need
to be able to deploy actors to it so if
we set the start up project to contain a
co console as well and we start
everything we then get a third window ah
and we can now see Oh No sorry I forgot
to check out the right branch
[Music]
you
so now it's listening on and now we can
see here that the message is that
previously we're in this one here are
now being printed out in this window
instead so the actors then being
deployed now this went wrong so we just
continue because as luck would have it
we now have lots of minus ones and if we
refresh here we'll see that the same
thing is is happening as before but if
we want to do something that's even more
fun I've got this little thing here
connected and I have just copied over
the same console app that I built on my
machine and you can see here then I'm
just running it in mono and now it's
waiting for for things to be deployed to
it so if we then remove and this time I
will remember to check out the right
branch
[Music]
and start things again you will then see
takes a little while now the message or
the actor has now been deployed to the
raspberry pi and that could of course be
any machine anywhere in the world and
the system is still doing its thing we
can refresh it and watch it compute and
as soon as we can see the minus one here
it will supervise and restart and
recover just as it was doing before
so that
more or less concludes the demo so what
we learnt that we can use a system or
and we can create an actor/model that is
distributed over different machines and
it is very useful for making processing
pipelines so you have messages in you
need to process them somehow send the
result on and it lends itself well to
scaling both vertically and horizontally
or you can deploy many actors
horizontally or you can deploy to a
machine that has more oops we make
systems that can stay available even
though things go wrong and yeah
there are some resources here the Gita
is really really good the core
contributors are active there and there
is a good free bootcamp on Peter bridge
comm which is the company that actively
supports hacker and then I'm not even
going to try and pronounce that name
I'll just butcher it but he has a very
very good blog on Acker with both
examples in c-sharp
and in F sharp and then there are also
some nice Pluralsight courses so it's
pretty much it any questions